in the opening scene we are introduced
to Sophie Bauer a free-spirited 17 year
old girl who spends most of her time in
bars consuming narcotics and drinks her
parents often try to correct her
behavior through punishment but to no
avail one day her stepfather Carl who is
a notable figure in politics hosts a
party where many people are invited
Sophie appears to dislike Carl a lot so
she plans to embarrass him in front of
his colleagues with a smirk on her face
she enters the room with a cigarette and
starts talking bad about him Furious
Carl takes her to the corner and
reprimands her for her actions have you
seen how Justin Trudeau celebrates
Halloween I'm not that bad apart from
all this Sophie has a boyfriend named
Ben who works as a cashier at a
department store one day she meets him
in a bar and starts making out he
suddenly stops when he notices some
bruise on her arms and asks about it
Sophie finally opens up that her
stepfather often punishes her physically
with tears in her eyes she then proposes
that they get married so that she can
escape her parents however Ben explains
that it would be illegal due to their
age just then a group of strangers
arrived there forcibly restrained Ben
and sedate Sophie before taking her away
these individuals are revealed to be
associated with a rehabilitation boot
camp currently they are taking Sophie to
that camp under her parents consent the
reason is
Sophie's parents want to address her
behavioral issues or in simple terms
they want to straighten her up later
that evening Ben rushes to Sophie's
residence and learns from her parents
that she has been enrolled in an
advanced year-long program focused on
discipline Ben wonders how any parents
could do such a thing to their own
children but Sophie's mother justifies
it as an important measure to prevent
her from jeopardizing her future
elsewhere Sophie regains her
Consciousness and finds herself on a
boat alongside two other guys who have
been sent by their parents for causing
trouble just like her the trio are taken
to the boot camp facility owned by Dr
Norman Hale located on a remote island
somewhere in
upon getting off the boat they are taken
to the other side of the island where
they are received by the security
manager named Logan the teenagers are
forced to wear cuffs with sensors around
their ankles so that the security will
be alerted if they make any attempt to
escape even if they manage to escape the
Camp's security system they won't be
able to go any further because the
island is surrounded by a treacherous
ocean in the next scene Logan provides
the group with an overview of the Camp's
regulations emphasizing that the sooner
they understand the sooner they'll get
to return home with this he chains the
teenagers to the concrete slabs on the
seashore and leaves them to spend a
night there at midnight the teenagers
struggle badly as powerful sea waves
crash against the concrete to which they
are bound at times they are even
submerged inside water making it
difficult for them to breathe
fortunately all of them manage to hold
on in the morning the chains are
released and they are greeted by Dr Hale
he extends a welcome to the newcomers
into his Advanced Serenity achievement
program expressing that it'll teach the
necessary manners in discipline for
their lives he introduces the group to
Allen who has been in the camp for two
years and will be returning home in a
month Ellen imparts additional Camp
rules to the newcomers according to her
everyone should wear the black t-shirts
at first that represents their state of
mind as they go on improving they'll be
promoted to yellow and finally to the
white one Ellen also shares her personal
story of self-improvement having
overcome personal struggles stemming
from her weight and bullying as the
weeks pass Sophia gradually adapts into
the camp routine and also befriends a
fellow Camp member named Trina one day
Dr Hale calls everyone inside a small
Hut and confronts Trina since she has
been in the camp for six weeks it's time
for her to confess her sins
uncomfortable and ashamed she hesitates
to do so this leads other members to
yell and push her subjecting her to
bullying of the worst kind finally Trina
reveals that her parents who are
religious adherents forbid her from
being with boys regardless she once
accepted a dare from friends to seduce
numerous boys and slept with seven in a
single night she expresses remorse for
her actions and seeks forgiveness after
hearing this the other Camp members try
to comforter saying that she will be
fine on the other hand Ben is very
worried for Sofia so he starts searching
for the boot Camp's whereabouts when he
doesn't find any leads he resorts to the
use of Narcotics hoping that it can lead
him to the boot camp the plan works and
when his parents find him engaged in the
illegal substance they decide to send
him to the same boot camp they must be
giving out coupons Fiji ain't sheep back
in the camp Trina steals a portion of
chicken to eat in secret unfortunately
Logan catches her in the act and warns
her about the potential consequences of
her actions Trina requests that he
overlooked the incident and he agrees on
the condition that she gives him
something in return following this he
walks closer to her and forces himself
upon her for Trina doesn't speak a word
because she wants to get out of his Camp
as soon as possible that night a storm
destroys the Camp's tents forcing the
teenagers to run it out the following
morning Trina is selected as the leader
of black t-shirts and the girls are
instructed to reconstruct their tents
after a long period of work Sophia
becomes tired and seeks to take some
rest however Trina prevents her from
resting highlight lighting that one
person's lapse could result in
punishment for all when Sophia resists
Trina orders the other girls to beat her
up later Sophia is undressed and left to
endure the cold and dampness of a room
the next day Dr Hale summons Sophia to
talk to her in private he offers her a
glass of milk and some cookies in
exchange for her deepest Secrets fair
trade however she throws the cookies
away and refuses to play these
psychological games what do I look like
Santa Claus [__] several weeks
later a new batch of teenagers are
brought into the boot camp including Ben
during dinner that evening he discreetly
sits across from Sophia although she
feels relieved to see him her expression
remains neutral knowing that they have
to hide their relationship later they
pretend to wash dishes to talk to each
other Sophia inquires how he arrived at
the camp to which Ben reveals that he
used some narcotics he also explains how
he spent weeks tracking down this Camp
hearing all of this Sophie breaks down
in tears but Ben assures her they will
flee the camp soon before departing he
hides a fork in his pocket indicating
that there's something going on in his
mind he wants to use the sharp edge of
the to deactivate his censored cuffs the
following morning the boys are taken for
a jog along the seashore during which
Ben spots a Fisherman's Boat later that
evening Dr Hale gathers all the
teenagers and publicly announces Trina's
promotion to the yellow level here's
your P shirt Trina it is later revealed
this promotion was possible because
Logan vouched for her in return he wants
to have more intercourse with her since
Sophia's Presence at the boot camp has
exceeded a month Dr Hale prompts her to
confess her misdeeds in front of
everyone when she hesitates Sophia
becomes the target of bullying by
certain tormentors chosen by Dr Hale
eventually overwhelmed with emotion she
tearfully admits that she lied about her
stepfather molesting her as days passed
by Ben methodically examines the entire
boot Camp's layout including the cuff
sensor detector and the control room
operated by Dr Hale and his sister
Rhonda in the process he also learns the
method to deactivate the ankle cuffs
using the fork one day Dr Hale leaves
for a conference in Los Angeles and Ben
takes it as the perfect opportunity to
escape with his girlfriend at the stroke
of midnight when everyone is asleep he
arrives at fears tend to execute their
escape plan together they exit their
tents and stealthily infiltrate Dr
Hale's office to retrieve their
passports as well as their personal
belongings to their luck Rhonda is sound
asleep due to heavy alcohol consumption
allowing them to escape without any
problem Ben successfully deactivates
Sophia's cuff and they board the local
farmer's boat to flee the island
meanwhile in Los Angeles Dr Hale
convenes a meeting with the parents of
troubled teenagers currently enrolled in
the boot camp during this session Ben's
father recounts the unexpected
behavioral changes his son underwent
after his girlfriend left him hearing
this Dr Hale senses something is a mess
so he quickly calls Logan to check on
the couple but by this time Ben and
Sophia are already out in the middle of
the ocean amid their Oceanic escape the
couple is faced with the big waves that
flip their boat forcing them to swim
despite the challenges they somehow
managed to reach the coastline where
they spot a hotel the couple then books
the hotel and arranges a flight for
their journey home that night they
decide to have some private time in
their hotel room however their intimacy
is interrupted by sudden arrival of
Logan and his men Logan strikes Ben hard
on his face and takes the two of them
back to the camp once they return the
couple is confined within a deep pit as
their punishment Dr Hale who has already
returned mentions that the consequences
of their escape attempt will be shared
by everyone he then announces a penalty
that there will be no breakfast or free
time for three months the days pass and
we see Ben and Sophia staying in the pit
even as rainwater accumulates within
after two whole weeks they are
eventually released from the Pit's
confines Dr Hale then summons Ben for a
private conversation and says that he
almost spoiled Sophia's Improvement
status so in order to ensure that Ben
does not interfere with his work anymore
Dr Hale decides to send him home in a
few days in addition he threatens that
if Ben does not comply with him he will
turn his girlfriend's life into a Hell
in the aftermath of this event Ben's
Behavior towards Sophia becomes distant
puzzled by his behavior Sophia inquires
and Ben informs her that the only way
she can leave the camp is by completing
the program additionally Ben reveals
that he's set to leave the camp soon
which deeply saddensed Sophia bringing
tears to her eyes in the midst of all
this Logan continues to force Trina to
satisfy him one night his actions
escalate beyond the limits as he
forcibly tears Trina's clothes and hurts
her later at midnight Sophia hears Trina
crying uncontrollably so she goes to
check on the matter although hesitant at
first Trina eventually opens up to Sofia
and the latter provides her with a
comforting hog the following morning the
boys are assigned to jog around the camp
and then partake in ocean swimming
unlike the others a guy named Daniel
doesn't know how to swim so he hesitates
to enter the water but despite his
reluctance he's compelled to proceed as
the water deepens Daniel struggles and
begins to drown seeing this Ben decides
to help him but Logan stops him from
doing so as a result Daniel succumbs to
drowning and his lifeless body is washed
ashore by the tide Ben rushes to perform
CPR but it's already too late fueled by
anger he accuses Logan of Daniel's death
but the latter refuses to take the blame
saying it was merely an accident
afterward the lifeless body is brought
into the camp and Dr Hale is a sad to
see this he directly confronts Logan and
imposes a suspension from his duties
later that same day Dr Hale convenes a
meeting where he proclaims that the
Camp's law is equal to all implying it's
now Logan's turn to admit his sins the
teenagers press him to confess that he
killed Daniel but Logan refuses just
then Trina steps forward and inquires
about the number of girls he has
assaulted several other girls stand with
her revealing that Logan has committed
the heinous act many times the teenagers
then surround him and start beating him
with sticks not long after Ben announces
to the shocked teenagers that this isn't
the first death to occur on a camp run
by Dr Hale he also points out the
baseless rules of the camp claiming that
such brutal programs are unnecessary for
personal development he convinces
everyone that this program is crap and
they should all destroy it right away
persuaded by Ben's words the teenagers
unleash chaos setting fire to the entire
campsite even Rhonda is no longer on her
brother's side amidst the Chaos Logan
attempts to flee in his car but the
teenagers Force his vehicle into a
burning structure leading to his demise
after this their attention shifts to Dr
Hale who tries to shoot them in hopes of
regaining control however turns out that
Rhonda has unloaded his weapon enabling
the teenagers to capture him he is then
thrown into solitary confinement
awaiting the police for his arrest as
the film Fades out scenes depict the
teenagers celebrating their Newfound
Freedom swimming in the ocean a screen
message appears indicating that since
the 1970s when such camps were
introduced in real life over 40 deaths
have been it subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching